okay and so here's the game that we're
going to be looking at this is Petrosian
versus Fischer this is in a Bobby
Fischer's memorable games number three
you did some of them it's number three
yeah I was gonna embark on reading every
single one of them once I got like
halfway through um he goes into great
detail it's a fantastic book it's one of
the best chess books we shut the door
that's like spiders out there and snakes
is scary in what's out there and your
sister right that's the scariest thing
my only complaint about this book is
that every single game is like a
Sicilian or a King's Indian which is
fine but it just kind of gets old for me
after a while I like seeing a whole
bunch of different openings every time
which I guess just reflects the way I
play I always play something different
because openings are not the problem I
struggle with so ah that's the only
thing if you don't like those two
openings and you're not gonna like the
book because that's basically every
single game and we'll read a little bit
from his book he nicknamed this game
bear hug and it looks like there's
notation here already on chess base
so maybe this is Fisher's notation maybe
it's not if I need to turn that off
we'll do it without the notation he
calls a bear hug because Petrosian with
the white pieces here actually really
squeezes him so it's a great middle game
lecture because it's how to slowly
improve your pieces and Petrosian and
Fischer had completely different styles
Fischer 1x wild sacrifice everything and
petrosyan just likes to be this much
better and then slowly increases
advantage and it grows and grows so it's
a battle of two completely different
styles and in this game Wade actually
emerged from the opening with a really
position and so you might think this is
in English but it's it's in this book so
by necessity it'll eventually become a
Kings Indian even though d3 was played
yeah you're not going to you're not
going to CD for coming are you
but after Knight to h5 here we'll start
looking after the move d4 d3 d4 and
white gets the better position so white
is hoping that this slight loss of time
is justified by the fact that the knight
is a little bit out of play had you just
gone
d4 immediately in this position normal
King's Indian black plays e5 normal
fianchetto Kings Indian but okay he's
like alright I'm going to exploit the
fact that you made this Knight move over
here and add just gain some space and
let's play this position so so far so
good
alright we'll see all right in d5 so
here we'll we'll see if we'll give you
guys one more move and then here's
blacks big plan f5 okay so very King's
Indian like and I guess I'll start to
see if the class can play like Petrosian
from from here on out is he going to
shut it all the way
he did it
so here actually uh okay a very common
idea when they play a five you take it
and black has to decide how to take it
back I always play he takes out five is
fine build your teacher you just you've
seen him because he's got a hundred
thousand lectures alright welcome what's
up
so you wanna take with a pond mm-hmm
yeah you're thinking about you want to
take with the least valuable which is
not the problem
yeah so he does analyze this he says
this is actually very tempting he's
attempting but unsound is this move okay
he sees g4 obviously so he's like this
is okay here half my night is there any
real compensation here for black sort of
no not really
I mean Fischer analyzing and everything
he does is like forty moves long like
this he just keeps going and going and
going he like never stops till like the
game is over
even the simplest thing is like airs all
the way to the end of the game which is
impressive because he didn't have a
computer and it's also remarkable how
well he did you know if you fact check
it with a computer he's mostly right but
here black actually can get a lot of
compensation here I'm just threatening
to get the piece back I'm attacking f3
for the third time
here
yeah boom so there's this sacrifice with
the idea of going here and he says white
is better so he can calculate this so
just because he's getting forked it
doesn't mean it's necessarily unplayable
so here okay there's going to be some
trades I'm going to take like ropes and
bishops and okay it's gonna be really
complicated so there's certainly
compensation but white should be better
according to Fisher so that's actually
an interesting way to take back but it
doesn't quite work out for black ok so
there's three other ways to capture is
so Fisher grip on
if you take what the rope you still get
formed and you don't well what if you
play Brooke here oh wait now so this
thinking what the rope obviously makes
the least sense but the sounds on so
it's good and Simon will be happy when
he hears that he'll say it was too soft
yeah okay what happens if I take with
the bishop this is an interesting
question yeah kind of prevents much fun
moving forward this one yeah G for no
longer is an option so that's what's the
downside of taking with the bishop
I mean you do it over this knee is like
some wild tactical continuation
because the black pieces don't have
enough squares because yeah what's the
bishop doing there and it's also given
white access here to the e4 square so
you can go here and you might be
thinking he's going to go here but he's
probably Fischer so he's going to play
typical Kings Indian sacrifice jumping
in to e6 so he analyzes the sacrifice
okay it's a it's a very typical pawn
sacrifice so very King's Indian like and
you know it line it just keeps going
forever I take here and I go back and if
you take here here and he says white is
better obviously obviously you can't
take because okay check so returning
taking with the pond which is what
happened in the game controls a lot more
squares
I guess we're looking at different roles
in this point of view I guess we could
flip it but I kind of like it from this
point of view so he takes here which
controls okay several squares here and
Petrosian is probably happy because the
pawn structure is slightly compromised
for black the King's a little bit
exposed Fischer's probably happy dynamic
compensations so everybody's happy right
now
a little tactic and this was we had to
see this coming when the knight was
placed here so obviously it is sort of
weird to play f5 and take back with the
pawn you know just leaving this guy
vulnerable so white just did he just
went upon nine takes g3 you remember
this do you remember which way he took
back because it surprised mr. Fisher
he says after H cakes simple and good I
had expected F takes but Petrosian
issues the King side attack in place for
control of the center instead his
judgment turns out to be right which
again just sort of highlights the
difference between the two players
petrosian's like thinking positionally
you know it's controlled the center and
officials linking go attack and you know
get these give these pawns go in and get
some pressure on the F I'll but okay so
Petrosian plays it for Trojan move and
again how to take back now we're going
to take the knight but there's two ways
to do it
so he gives the way that he took back a
question mark okay and that's what he
did I mean he says he doesn't like it he
says here offers him more play so he's
going to play boobs like 84 we can
reroute this night into the action your
question makes more sense this way
right and that's exactly what happens he
takes with the bishop and then all of
his kingside play is gone yeah that's
what happened
so yeah the white just goes on to get a
very good position after this point okay
f4 again just designed minimizing any
kingside play you might have if I can
take away all of your Kings side play
and I can start getting focused here on
the Queen side was like d4 c5 that's
sort of a thing the way it's been
playing very patient he's just sort of
waiting trying to restrict all of the
counter play that black might have and
that's just that's his style of play
obviously is he's happy you want double
my pawns that'd be fine but Fischer
wisely keeps the dark squared bishop
because he's made a lot of dark squared
weaknesses around his King all right and
now another simple move so okay it's a
middle game class and all he really does
is he just constantly improves his
pieces here and tries to it seems to
goals restrict all of blacks counter
play because eventually we're going to
win on the Queen side and just improve
all of the pieces he's just he's very
good at just getting his pieces to good
squares there's there's certainly more
than one right move here but I guess
what would the audience play in this
position is white okay a very good
concept yeah we want the knight on e6
and rook on e one this is definitely a
part of the plan and so yeah there are a
lot of good answers you're working on
perfectly fine move it just keep it with
the idea of eventually we're going to
try to get our Knight there
and Bishop e3 also makes sense with with
your idea we're going to try to trade
off the dark squared Bishop this is sort
of a one of the best pieces for black
he's a really good defender ant attacker
so if we can weaken the dark squares by
making this trade and we're we're doing
very well
wait and it's exactly what ended up
happening okay Bishop d4 now in this
position a very very tough move here so
what
so try to understand so we're going to
play as white let's try to understand
what black wants to do let's try to
think prophylactically here which okay
which fish
Petrosian is typically good at but it's
neither player saw this idea that was
possible here for for black if it's
white Stern but you play here which
Fisher holds careless but he didn't find
a way to get activity so as move
actually is really tough I think finding
the right move at least according to
Fisher is a is a tall order
so okay let's just put this on the board
for a second we're going to come right
back in this position how does black get
some activity here each five so yeah
exactly
so this is what I guess both players
missed an H five with the ideas of H
four in the future and you like black
right and so both players actually
missed this idea so that's that's good I
would glad we're able to find that so
what what at least does Fisher think
that white should play in this position
Bishop takes g7 yeah okay probably
I think white certainly doesn't mind you
taking and bringing my queen to the
center it's a good diagonal yeah so he
gives Bishop f3 just preventing this
idea and he stops there but he's okay
this is the way to stop blacks potential
to get some counter play okay but here
and now not taking and playing h5 rook
f7 which will see if he makes one
himself he says black doesn't get a
second chance because okay this time to
Trojan plays it
Bishop f3 just aimed at preventing h5 in
the future
weena fate what's the idea
makes room yeah that's definitely a part
of it so we can we get trained and who
wants to trade a lot of stuff here white
wants to trade a lot of stuff who wants
to trade stuff black wants to trade this
stuff white has more space Black's a
little bit cramped when it's obviously a
little bit better he's black doesn't
have anything going on this side of the
board
white at some moment here we'll be able
to play b-45 that sort of idea and okay
it's black that wants to trade stuff so
perhaps we take in Queen g7 and trade
lots of stuff Dany Machuca style his
favorite kind of chess okay
he brought the king in sometimes
sometimes I might use the h-file my
Kings a little bit closer alright just a
good move and we get the straight let's
trade lots of stuff all right
we traded all the stuff
24
now black plays a prophylactic move so
there's a lot of stuff has happened so
anytime there's these massive trades we
want to kind of stop for a second and
rethink the position because it's
changed quite substantially in nature
now that a lot of things have left the
board and so here it's you know becoming
a little more obvious that white is just
about ready to start playing on the
queenside black still has nothing going
on the kingside so we're looking at
moves like c5 maybe B 4 and C 5 so a
common way to prevent that will be 6
there might be some light-sport issues
in the future but ok we we need to sort
of stop this move here and then after
here which ii sorry what is effortlessly
achieved the plus and now he wants to
improve his position before embarking on
the committal course which is of course
the move b4 which threatens c5 is much
sharper imposes more immediate problems
so if pitcher or white you would have
played the move b4 so he kind of
criticizes the move rook h1 although
white is still better it gives black
time to play the move
a5 ok so black has been able to at least
for the moment deter all sorts of Queen
side play at some point you might want
to play a 3 and B 4 but he's trying to
make it as difficult as possible
what's the idea 91 house and this is
what petrosian's good at okay here e
maneuvers all of his pieces to better
squares
let me go after the c-7 pond
getting the night to be five mm-hmm
which is interesting and then okay so of
course if you put a night here and you
take white has this pressure along the C
file but perhaps it's not enough we have
a Roca Queen we have lots of ways to
defend our week on will it be enough it
wasn't quite as idea in this position
he's going after a five-time USA
you might put his knight on d3
what's your knight doing on d3 just
supporting c5 so supporting b4 + c5
these sort of pushes which also I mean
again there's not like there's just one
right or wrong move but he decides he's
going to go after the weakness he's you
know he's very patient and I'll do stuff
over here a lot later a lot later I just
want to start focusing on what's going
on over here
so one way of attacking it is ninety
three and you might also consider Rhema
nuvaring his Bishop to d3 the trojan
keeps building without getting
sidetracked even by good moves I was
more afraid of a certain move tying me
down completely so what's what's the tie
em down completely move this is this is
a tricky one I think a four
well even if this doesn't blender upon
we probably don't want to play this
because now how are you ever going to
play B 4 and C 5
93 was played in the game so it's not
subtly and it just it ties them down so
this actually is a very clever move that
could have been played so should we try
it yeah how does why is this move so
good what does this move prevent the
rook from moving because if Brooke here
we can take the knight yeah open the H
file and okay white wins so that's
that's the move Fisher was afraid of
makes sense but I can't I already said
yeah it doesn't get sidetracked even
biting the boobs that's that's kind of
funny it's a polite jest at his opponent
okay so he's going after the F pawn the
bishop would come over the rook can go
to h5 we can get lesser pressure here
and obviously White is still better
that's why he calls this game the bear
hug because he is just getting squeezed
here like he's getting hugged from a
bear alright so now he gets to play this
move spoilers well it's the very first
thing bear oh yeah okay
and now just another nice move here of
my black I still want to trade pieces
let's just trade he's the cramp
and okay you either trade or you go off
up for that really nice diagonal so
you're you're basically compelled to
take otherwise you would just be helping
black out
a three eventually yeah rights move 28
I'm going to get started over there
eventually
maybe I'll I want to play B four at a
time in which maybe I can swing over to
the a file come along to the Sabbath
rank get even more pressure slowly
building all right so now if B for which
I think e does he mention it this in the
notes if B for now it actually be a
mistake this is what black is trying to
prevent because now it is black tickets
to go over to the a file so this would
be a big mistake but that's fine boys
probably be really patient continue with
the slow moves but okay he's like my
other plan was attacking your F pawn
there should be two Bishop d3 rook h5
protects this stuff
someday I would like to go here someday
or maybe here you know someday I have
these dreams interesting
coming up now with a another very
fascinating point of the game so a
tactical move quite a nice move women
let's see if we can understand this
there should be eight totally blundering
the f-bomb why did he move a defender
what this is just silly right why would
Bobby Fischer do that what's the idea
here
what if I if I just take this right
kingi six so kingi six okay
check
and check
you just take that's the take with the
rook Bishop g6 I'll take your up yeah
you'll take back I'll take that somehow
you don't get on the plane bishop g6
well you do but you don't want the rooks
attacking each other
all right the rook strap so you can move
your up away how funny is that
ah the rook ends up getting trapped yeah
the next move now is Bishop g6 so Wow I
mean that's just fantastic I really I
really like that move Bishop e8 that's
just genius
he also analyzes this funny booth and
then what does he think black should
play is great it's the great move
obviously you're laughing so I think you
know - this rook h8 your rooks trapped
Bishop d6 yeah I don't want your
exchange I'm just gonna yeah I'll get
did in a different way so that's great
okay fantastic move was probably my
favorite moving the game rook age - why
not rook h1 nobody knows better gauge to
this fine move okay 56
let's see
so it's funny we're gonna see this again
he moves his rope one square then he
moves it one more square we're gonna see
that again let's just let's just relive
that in slow motion you got that vent
silent rook age two Brooke age one okay
remember that there's going to be a
similar maneuver coming up you know why
I go somewhere in one time when you do
it in two moves you know and it's that
is sort of how many plays he likes to
play cat-and-mouse he likes to just sort
of wait and wait and wait which okay
it's a very professional attitude you
never want to do anything because it's
chess he's just waiting maybe Bobby will
do something you'll do something crazy
you know I don't know she's gonna lash
out violently somewhere and then you'll
make weaknesses and you'll he'll blunder
the game away that's what he's waiting
for you just waiting never gauge to or
gauge one I just wait no I mean we'll
just move 33 but I don't think it's time
pressure I think that's just a style he
that's what he does if I mean if you can
do something in one move or if you can
do it in five moves you'll do it in five
moves that's his style it gives you more
time to make mistakes because I mean
what's black gonna do how is black going
to get counter play here it's it's not
very obvious so he's just waiting you
know bear-hugging Bobby Fischer and okay
it's just waiting for you to just
collapse so okay black has to be very
patient and just also do nothing but
alright they were both able to do that
in this game night to see 2x clam headed
for an even stronger post on d4 I was
amazed during the game each time to
Trojan achieved a good position he
managed to maneuver into a better one
you wanna come in just just make sure
that doors shut because you know you
were out there and you're scary all
right
we've been talking about you a lot
mostly good but mostly good okay just a
nice little patient move 94 that's where
he's going okay looking at some of these
light squares
nothing nothing's ever happening look
where each fly all right
look age five did you play rogue age
five again okay I probably play King of
six again you know and then you're going
to play rook here Brooke here Brooke
here and rook back and then then we'll
do something else then you make time
yeah before do mangoforty if you do it
that way yeah it's nice to try out all
these squares how could he play so bad
you know I could have gone rook here
then rookie working record one more
waiting much more professional Bishop e2
but he's just pretending he's like I'm
gonna go here I'm gonna go here I'm
gonna go here but he's just pretending
it's all a joke he doesn't actually do
that fainting an invasion with Bishop h5
rookie 196 White has two wings to
operate on black must be flexed to react
appropriately and this requires
alertness and having said that he says
he panics and gives his opponent the
opportunity he's been waiting for but he
didn't do it okay
he says here and he says this is a
mistake
why would you think this is a mistake
well he criticizes this movement looks
pretty good I'll go to g4 that's good
what does this possibly allow before but
Petrosian didn't do it or he did do it
yeah did he do it yeah he did do it
before and so this is what what I just
assumed he wouldn't do anything because
he's Petrosian I thought he'd just keep
waiting this is what he's been waiting
for the opportunity that when the a file
opens up it's white that gets his rook
over to the a file and up to the seventh
rank okay yeah so he says instead he
should play rook a a and only then after
some random maneuvers I think he gives
this crazy line and something okay some
crazy line okay so let's go back to the
game Knight G a question mark b4
Petrosian does something I move 37
that's one that's when you should start
pushing your Queen side move 37 very
patient player all right this was
obviously his idea
Bishop d3 so if you put your knight
there I'll take you I undid the squares
okay you might check me but I'm going to
start moving over to the other side you
can check on them that would be
unprofessional
he took here
you have to defend this is when attacked
twice and now it's white it conquers the
a file so okay again he's still getting
squeezed he's still getting hugged by a
bear here let's move 40 so the wait is
finally achieved his ideal setup the
blacks game is still tenable all right
professionals they wait 2 or 3 moves and
then check it's the professional way
more checks now it is this the funny
move rid so you remember the the funny
Brook stuff on the H file you're gonna
like these moves to rook a 6 ok possibly
c5 stuff and my ropes on the same thing
here ok same right that was good you got
there in two moves just like yeah right
d3 d4 you hittin rook h2 h1 rook a 6 a 7
he's the best ok now the next move white
plays here he says well I guess reading
this will give away this pawn sac caught
me completely by surprise it's the only
line that gives black any trouble so
which pawn sack
okay okay yeah so what is what is this
sacrifice though why is he giving up a
pawn here
so that you can clear the six rank and
No
two pieces for a rookie you say just
kidding
Jesus off you saw a line okay
we've sacrificed a pawn but okay they're
not the strongest pawn here comes the
night he's jumping into e5 very nice
dark square for the knight with a bishop
can take them and okay he gives this as
a major air because even the lowest
rated among us will find a 95 check for
King the king and Bishop okay good okay
so so that's funny thing Fisher would
analyze that he normally doesn't able
eyes hey those are the lines but he's
very thorough okay
so instead the King goes here you're
going to get checked but now it's the
king that can go over and defend the
bishop very
so an interesting decision he's going to
go ahead and win this f5 pond but
obviously giving away a very nice night
all right but ponds are ponds so that's
what happens yeah this is what happened
this is the game broken Bishop is much
better than rook and Knight because you
watch every final lecture so pretty soon
here we in there we're going to come to
an end game he analyzes this move like a
thousand moves deep it's a draw
alright so g4 and so very interesting
endgame and now I'm mistake he plays
King to six should be the losing move
exclam correct is what move
so again everything's changed a lot of
stuff has happened
me okay so he says night f6x clam
all right and now brace yourself
you can take and okay okay collecting
all these ponds it's it's going to be a
draw
he probably analyzes it four thousand
removes but all right that's enough but
instead he played here we should be the
losing move which might make you think
that he didn't lose I need to be right
all right so now he took X clam we give
this very fascinating endgame so white
for the moment is upon up King III
rookie a so be be careful which way is
the king going to go
he's going to go to the queenside he
didn't go to the coin side because he
did not because of blacks next move here
so if here black has a move that will
okay result in the drawn position yeah
Ricky eight yeah okay so you're you're
losing this guy so for that reason okay
he has to go to the Kings side which yes
and that a bit scary this isn't okay
doesn't that feel a little uh-oh
so that's that's what's happening here
rook a6 sure
so very interesting and now both players
have to pass pawns
assuming this pawn is fast maybe it's
not who knows what so I do want to show
okay you can get the book for yourself
it's a good book and go through every
single possible line he said white could
have played rook h7 and then you know
sixty moves from now it wins or whatever
crazy thing he says well just look at
rook h1 this was a game he says question
mark and there's going to be a reason
that I'm showing you this game at the
very end for those of you that were in
the last class so okay so here comes the
pond marches some thousand moves a
thousand moves DP these people here
could see it you can't see it at home
but it just keeps going and going and
going it never stops
but the ending you'll see why I want to
show this to you guys
okay it's what's going on here yeah how
is it yeah it's a very interesting read
what's going on here
you know it's drawn because somebody
spoiled in okay it's it was drawn but it
doesn't really spoil it I mean how I got
to puns I'm gonna make it Queen right
aren't I a thousand times faster and
here the game was agreed to a draw but
we're going to find out why and here he
says his final thing of this game I
offered the draw not realizing it was
bad etiquette
it was petrosian's plays to extend the
offer after the move that we're gonna
look at here as a class so let's just
for a minute here let's imagine we're
black I mean that's yeah I'll call on
you later
um let's imagine we're black and let's
give people a chance how would ya how
are you gonna how you gonna draw this
I've never come on you I might
and there's more than one answer so
fruitcakes g6 drones because it's a
bishop oh yeah this guy went to the
lecture so here's here's the answer
it's a bishop pond in the king what's we
remember the other magic squares the
king is on the short side here the other
white one which one we're on the short
side so e7 right V 2 d2
this one is it on the short side d2 and
if the white cane is one square away
from either of these it would be a win
for white let's uh let's make these it's
very it's tough to tell if the king is
close enough so it's our last chance to
color anything tonight um nope he's not
quite in the box so this would indeed be
a draw and again just to repeat okay
it'd be the same sort of scenario where
okay you can keep doing this and then
still make me whenever you want and he
does he does give a second way so that's
good that was his main line there's a
second way
anyway it's it's the same sort of idea
it's a little bit funnier rook anywhere
and I go I go do this and came somewhere
and we get the same scenario so I did
give two ways it was funny because I
showed this to somebody else and they
immediately saw that but not rook g6 I
thought this was the more obvious choice
so I like the other one I like this only
because it was less obvious to me at
least it's ok so that was a nice little
Fischer game sort of tied in there at
the end to the last lecture so thank you
guys from coming out and if you liked
the video hit like share subscribe and
I'll see you guys next week
you